well the popularity of at-home genetic
tests to screen for diseases is growing
we're looking at the benefits and
drawbacks this morning in our series
Grand Rounds that's the practice of
medical professionals teaching other
doctors about advancements this month
the FDA approved the first
direct-to-consumer tests in the u.s.
that's designed to find three Jun Jie
mutations linked to breast cancer
without a doctor's prescription this is
just the latest in a growing number of
cheaper and easier genetic tests that
can reveal information about your
ancestors risks for certain diseases or
even why you're sensitive to bitter
taste some tests can be done for less
than $100 our David agus is here with
more and let's talk about 23andme I've
actually done it I want to ask you about
that later yeah what can it predict
exactly and and what are some of the
concerns that doctors have about it well
I can tell you your ancestry they could
tell you how you metabolize caffeine but
it's not going to tell you some of the
really serious health traits that you
probably care about so they just got FDA
approval for three of over a thousand
mutations that can cause rest and
ovarian cancer that's only three of them
so or worries me as if you're taking I'm
not at high risk but you may have one of
the other nine hundred plus there are
other at-home tests that require a
doctor to sign off on it but you could
do it at home you spit into a tube you
send it in that could look for all of
the mutations in the brca1 and brca2 n--
2 gene which is risk for breast and
ovarian cancer
remember when Angelina Jolie you know
heroically announced I have this gene
five years ago it was $4,000 for the
test now it's been democratized for less
than 100 yeah that is incredible should
everyone including men consider getting
tested for the bracha gene men are just
as likely as women to be carriers of the
bracha gene and so I'm a believer yes
knowledge is power if you have it you
want to intervene 70 plus percent chance
of breast cancer 40 plus percent chance
of ovarian cancer both of which can
dramatically change your life in your
family's life so yes I believe you
should David you just said you spit into
a two but let me tell you when I did 23
me it's a whole lot of spitting so how
I've seemed to do it I think you can
no I could do it I can put up I can it
was not a problem I have a lot of saliva
but how easy or difficult is it to take
the test generally speaking what taking
the test is easy yeah it takes you know
ten minutes fifteen minutes to spend
into the tube what's important to me
though is that there either be a doctor
or a genetic counselor involved because
this is serious stuff and I want to make
sure you really understand as the
consumer what's going on because big
decisions have to be made in either
direction this is what I remember during
our pregnancies there were lots of
different tests that we took and we get
the results back and it was madness
trying to figure out what they meant
what they meant relative to the
percentages it was very difficult and
frustrating and a little scary so how
does this avoid those problems but
before you answer I love how you said
our pregnancies our pregnancy you sort
of own it I like that well yeah a team
work but let's be very clear who did all
the work I don't want to suggest you but
I like now he says that our pregnancy
get stressful on the male I don't get it
get the know what we're talking this is
a very serious decision yes and so I you
know you're right it's not binary it's
not black and it's not white it's you
know relative risk and so whether it be
you're higher than average you know I
took the test myself my results were on
the front page of The Wall Street
Journal and I was higher risk for heart
disease it didn't mean I was going to
get it it's just the National risk
factor was 38% for a male of my age I
was in the high 40s I mean it changed
what I did and I really paid attention
but it's not a yes/no answer so you
really need somebody who understands it
to explain what are the downsides I'm
taking it the downsides are you gonna do
the wrong thing the downside says you're
not going to talk to someone who's going
to explain it and you know the other
downside is there are people who are so
the worried well that if I say you have
a higher than likely chance you're not
gonna sleep for the next six months
which certainly ain't good but for most
people knowledge is power all right dr.
agus knowledge is power you know that's
why know where the for it is and know
where the reverse is before you get on
at all things right thank you doctor